die sieben tage incidents entscheide
darüber ob deutschland wegen corona
dicht macht das war auch der grund warum
zum beispiel das konzert sich das
konzert sondern die veranstaltung von
der erich bei dass abgesagt wurde und
eben auch der grund warum keine
fußballfans da sehen wir gerade noch
einmal die bilder genau das wurde eben
abgesagt in köln haben ja gerade
ausführlich darüber gesprochen amsterdam
und wien wurden zu risikogebieten
erklärt und auch fußballfans mussten
kurzfristig draußen bleiben
die anzahl der korona kranken auf
intensivstationen betrug allerdings zu
diesem zeitpunkt in münchen gerade mal
in ganz bayern 41 haben wir wirklich die
richtige strategie schauen wir auf die
richtigen zahlen
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
philipp potthoff guten morgen findet wir
haben jetzt gehört sieben tage in sident
was ist das denn überhaupt und was sagt
ja dieser wert aus also bei der sieben
tage incidence werden ausschließlich die
infektionszahlen berücksichtigt diese
zahl sagt im prinzip wie viele neue
infektionen gab es in der letzten in der
vergangenen woche in den vergangenen
sieben tagen
und wenn es mehr als 35 neuinfektionen
auf 100000 einwohner in einem landkreis
oder einem kreis gibt dann ist dieser
diese obergrenze erreicht und dann gilt
es als besonders gefährdete kronlage und
dann werden auch maßnahmen eingeleitet
aber andere werte spielen da überhaupt
nicht rein also das lka und auch die
bundesregierung die fokussiert sich sehr
auf die infektionszahlen aber wenn es um
christianisierung zahlen oder schwere
verläufe oder todeszahlen geht die
fallen gerade ein bisschen runter geben
denn diese infektion zahlen überhaupt
die gefahr durch corona wieder
ja das ist ein frühindikator also man
will bei corona natürlich nicht zu spät
dran sein man will nicht erst maßnahmen
beschließen wenn die intensivstation
voll sind aber man muss sagen die
infektionszahlen und damit auch diese
sieben teil des events das ist ein
faktor von vielen ja es ist ein guter
frühindikator aber wir haben jetzt im
sommer gesehen
neben vergangenen wochen auch dass die
infektionszahlen zwar stark angestiegen
sind aber die hospitalisierung zahlen
also die zahlen der menschen die ins
krankenhaus mussten die zahlen der
menschen die auf intensivstationen
mussten
diesen sehr niedrig und ziemlich stabil
geblieben
wir sehen hier auch auf der karte wie
das mit den intensivstationen in
deutschland aussieht also zum beispiel
wie groß ist der anteil der kogit 19
patienten an der gesamtzahl der
intensivbetten und rechts gründen sieht
man beispielsweise bayern
da steht ein prozent das heißt ein
prozent aller entzünden sich eine aller
belegten intensivbetten wird von corona
patienten belegt das heißt von einer
überlastung durch corona kann derzeit
keine rede sein
ja auch wenn man sich mal berlin
anschaut wir haben derzeit in berlin
nicht einmal 20 corona patienten auf der
intensivstation gesprächen über eine
stadt mit über 35 millionen einwohnern
also der kollaps den unsere politik
immer verhindern wollte
der ist sehr weit weg und da steht uns
derzeit auch nicht bevor was würdest du
denn dann sagen was wäre ja eine
richtige zeit in betracht oder muss man
einfach mehrere zahlen zusammen nehmen
dann eine entscheidung treffen zu können
ja das könnte eine idee sein dass man
einen neuen chor ohne richtwert
entwickelt oder auch einfach mehrere
richtwerte hat der cdu politiker andreas
mattfeldt hat heute in der bild zeitung
gefordert dass es eben einen neuen krone
richtwert gibt in dem auch aus
vitalisierung zahlen und auch
intensivstation also die belegung der
intensivbetten berücksichtigt wird ein
lungenarzt hat kürzlich bei uns
gefordert dass deutschland auch mehr
infektionen zu lassen kann also eine
möglichkeit wäre natürlich einfach diese
obergrenze der infektion zu erhöhen von
35 50 oder 60 oder was auch immer
auf der anderen seite müssen wir muss
die politiker doch einfach formulieren
was sie welches ziel sie denn verfolgen
will
ich habe immer noch im kopf dass sie den
kollaps der krankenhäuser vermeiden will
wenn das immer noch das ziel ist dann
können wir uns deutlich mehr erlauben
als jetzt gerade der fall ist wenn die
politik plötzlich versuchen möchte jede
einzelne kommune infektion zu
unterbinden
ja dann sollte sie genauso weiter machen
aber ich weiß nicht wie lange die
bevölkerung das somit macht mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren